[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
nothing exceeds like excess
remember that old saying nothing
succeeds like success nothing oh nothing
succeeds
like success like success ah okay
of course excess comes in many shapes
and sizes excess stuff excess debt
excess screen time and commitments and
emotional clutter with all the
advertisements and stimuli we see every
day it feels like we're constantly
drinking from the fire hose
of excess
what excesses do you battle with in your
own life today on the minimalist podcast
ryan and i we're going to talk about
escaping the excess then this thursday
on the minimalist private podcast we're
going to talk about the pros and cons of
asceticism we'll also discuss the path
of aloneness and several reasons
we
as a society
are addicted to accumulation
you can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
before we get to our first question ryan
our good friend tk coleman
was supposed to be here today yeah
and
unfortunately
a couple days before
flying out here to be on the podcast for
his 11th appearance
he was hit by a car oh no man that's
crazy he and his wife are out doing
their evening walk walking across the
street someone turns left he's sort of
walking on the outside to protect
michelle and
the car just hits him
and he goes on top of it and then goes
onto the ground he's all scraped up beat
up
and concussed it appeared because when
the emts arrive they're asking him his
name how many fingers am i holding up
etc questions to see how with it he is
in the moment he couldn't answer any of
them unbelievable i didn't realize his
wife was with him yeah wow so he did
protect her yes and she was she was fine
and in fact she's the one who ended up
calling you know to get the ambulance
and and make sure that he was safe and
unfortunately he was hit by a car and
i'm just so grateful that
he'll be okay i mean he's in a lot of
pain right now so if you want to send
him your love your prayers your well
wishes you can reach out to him on
twitter or instagram
he's at tk underscore coleman on twitter
at officialtk coleman on instagram we'll
put a link to those in the show notes
and just say that we're uh we're
thinking about him we appreciate him
we often call him the third minimalist
and he's gonna be spending some more
time out here on the podcast with us
in the coming months hopefully but in
the meantime let's send him some well
wishes yeah
yeah he'll appreciate it reach out to
him on twitter alexandria has a question
from facebook to start the episode
at what point does something become
excessive
excessive so
one person's excess might be
too much for them
but not enough for someone else so
in that
sense excess can be highly individual
and it got me thinking as i was
preparing for this episode and i thought
about alexandra's question here
the um
definition
of success or really the synonyms for
success
surplus
over abundance super abundance
over sufficiency
profusion plethora
glut
um
too much more than enough
enough
well here's the thing more than enough
is probably
the best way to think about excess
profusion
but if we have more than enough then we
have excess right
we have too much of a thing there are a
whole bunch of sayings about this about
too much of a good thing will ruin it
right when you think about
yes i enjoy eating ice cream or whatever
right yeah but if they bring me 15 bowls
of ice cream one after another i have a
glut
of ice cream and it becomes miserable
there's a bell curve and it starts to
become miserable after a while and that
bell curve you get to that enough point
and enough
means we our needs are met the material
possessions that we have
are augmenting or enhancing our
experience of life but then when we get
too much those things begin to get in
the way of what's actually going to
enhance our life
and so when i am dealing with excess
when i'm trying to get rid of excess
it's because i'm trying to get back to
that enough point um
yeah man i think
you know when it becomes excessive for
me with different things it it uh
it
evokes invokes evokes
certain feelings yeah so
i think about like the food example
um yeah you eat i eat too much and then
i physically feel heavy
i feel bloated
i feel tired um if i am what what really
um what this really makes me think of is
the enneagram at home a seven and like
you know the whole deadly sin is glutton
gluttony
um
when it comes to things in my life like
if my account calendar is over full or
if i'm just doing too much and it could
be too much
of a good thing of good things like um
making plans with friends going out to
dinner going to a concert going to the
comedy club you know doing all the
things that cause i try to do all the
things in los angeles it's impossible to
do all the things in l.a at the same
time your plate spinning yeah right
exactly exactly um i start to feel
anxious i started to feel like this
jittery
um
i can tell that like i need to slow down
type of feeling because you have excess
obligations here right yeah and so it's
interesting how you talked about the
food thing making you feel bloated but
we become sort of psychologically
bloated yeah when we take on too much
excess in other areas of our lives yeah
you know the screen time is a big one
because it's so easy it's right there
it's that 79th organ that is in our
pocket right the new book i'm reading
right now is called the every it's dave
edgar's follow-up to the circle it's a
wonderful book it'll probably end up
being a added value on a future episode
we'll talk in depth about it but one of
the things it takes place in the near
future and everyone is now wearing their
phone on their forearm which seems like
a natural evolution because we don't
have it installed but it's effectively
installed in all of their arms so
they're constantly
looking down and scrolling the screen
that's on their arm and
i find and we have a question later
about sort of too much social media and
being disconnected because we're so
connected but also being afraid of
disconnecting because we think it's
going to disconnect us right yeah and so
the screen
the reason it's so pernicious is
it mimics or it apes the form
of
being productive right good getting
stuff done
yes yeah gtd
and also it's a status symbol look how
busy i am right
and
it's different for like an addiction to
say alcohol or cigarettes right because
no one is assuming at this point that
cigarettes are
healthful
at one point people actually did you
know four out of five doctors recommend
camel i smoked camel and doctors would
even at one point would prescribe
smoking to help with asthma that's why
it is what and yet we're doing a similar
thing now there are some things with
respect to our phones where they can be
really useful and that's why it's more
pernicious because this thing that is
useful
also really can get in the way and make
us miserable yeah that's the other thing
when i get too much phone time then i
start to feel
uh like a just a blob like i i'm like
dopamine deficient yes and you know i'm
on the phone trying to get those you
know more dopamine hits because i'm
dopamine deficient but really i'm just
like getting into the negative more and
the more i stay on the phone
um
what cracks me up man is i'll be like
looking at instagram and there's all
these instagram is basically tick tock
by the way like that's what they do with
with the the videos on instagram yeah we
call it tick tock too right yeah exactly
tick tock two
okay i'll be scrolling through these
videos and i'm like this is so stupid
why are they why are they doing this am
i going to the next video yeah this
person's an idiot too what are they
doing and then i go to the next video
i'm like why would you put this video
why would you put this out there of
yourself of doing these little dances
and and lip singing whatever it is and
then i quickly realized like wait a
minute i'm the idiot
[Laughter]
it's actually me who is the [ __ ] in
this situation oh man so ironic so uh
yeah and it and it is easy for me to
like get
into the the stream of tick tock man
whether it's like cat videos or
snowboarding videos or
whatever dude you know booty shaking
videos you know you know what tick-tock
is it's got everything yeah it makes me
every time i find myself going down that
rabbit hole i think of the uh social
dilemma
and i'm like
i'm like dude they they got you
like they know your algorithm yeah they
know you really really well yeah yeah
they know you better than you know you
yeah
yeah that's cool by the way the irony of
all this i think danny's going to
tick-tock the whole thing you just
talked about with respect to tick-tock
oh that's okay it'll be nice yeah ironic
we're going to feed the uh well here's
here's the hope of us using social media
right
is because ryan and i are often on the
fence with respect to do we even want to
be on social media at all anymore
but
how can we use it to add value and i've
been asking that question since 2009
how how can i add value but especially
when we started the minimalists in 2010
it was
asking whatever we do if i send a tweet
if i
publish a blog post if we make a film we
record a podcast will this add value
and if not then it's what it's excessive
yeah it's an egoic pursuit
and it's the effort of the ego look at
me look at me look at me
and then i just save it as draft and
then eventually go back and delete the
draft
because if it doesn't add value i don't
want to share it yeah
do you think
excessiveness does it always relate with
the pursuit of ego
because i mean i i i'm tempted to say it
is
interesting so
possibly yes and i wrote down a few
things they're in my bag though so i'll
pick them up here
in a minute but the
the ego isn't good or bad but it often
moves us in ways that move us away from
peace or contentment right
and in fact i wanted to talk about this
on the maxwell episode we might as well
talk about it now
there are
basically three ways to gain acceptance
from someone
there are three ways that you can get
other people to accept you
and the first way
is how most of us try and it's actually
the most difficult
we buy expensive things or do things to
try to impress people we do things to
place us on a pedestal
so you will look up to me
and that is one way to gain acceptance
look at my lamborghini look at my big
house look at my fancy suit look at my
purse with all of the logos on it look
at these things they say something about
me i'm up here on a pedestal and
therefore
i'm valid to you
that's incredibly difficult but it's
even more difficult to sustain because
you buy a brand new 2022
lamborghini
and eight years from now it's an
eight-year-old lamborghini how
impressive is that so you have to keep
feeding the beast in order to remain
valid it's not a strategy that works
long term yeah the second way is to
place yourself on the same level as
someone else well how do you do that
well by listening
by conversing by being with
someone not convincing them not forcing
your ideas onto them but merely being
with them one might call it compassion
or empathy
but what a great
a great step down
it's so much easier to get someone
else's acceptance by simply
listening to them by being there for
them and with them
right i love it the third way
is
to put yourself
below them
to serve other people
because if you really want acceptance
you don't need a lamborghini you don't
need a rolex you don't need a purse with
a bunch of logos on it
you can simply serve someone
you can help them because if you help
someone and they accept that help then
they're accepting you
for who you are
and here's the bonus fourth way
it's to
not need the acceptance at all ooh
because if i don't need your validation
your veneration i don't need you to
think a particular way about me then yes
i can still own the things i want to own
i don't need them to impress you anymore
i can still be with you because i want
to be with you but not because i need
your validation and then ultimately i
can still serve you
i can still help you
not because
you need me
but simply because
i need to help other people
and if i understand that
then i don't need your acceptance at all
i love it man that's great we got some
more questions here how about we dive
into
lisa's question from patreon
i see so many people who are overwhelmed
by the excess caused by workaholism
addiction and fomo how do we encourage
others to break away from these
people-pleasing behaviors
ultimately they're all addictions here
we're talking about so workaholism
is an addiction
now fomo is a little bit different the
fear of missing out
i want to talk about
the piece of missing out for a second
piece
p-e-a-c-e the piece of missing out i
really need to hear this right now homo
pomo
not post modern pomo but the piece of
missing out and so let's talk about this
so
you're in montana ryan yeah
and you're right there at the clark fort
river yeah
it's june and july people are
wading down the river they're tubing
right
now imagine if you tried to experience
all of the river
you couldn't you can't touch all of the
water and the stream even if it's a
small creek you can't
submerge yourself in the full stream
indefinitely
and yet you can still experience the
stream for what it is
in life
more broadly speaking is merely a stream
and we can dip our toes in the water
when we want or we can just sit back and
observe it you're not missing out on the
stream by observing it
you're experiencing peace by not needing
to dive in and take in every drop of it
hmm
yeah
i dig it man yeah i i really do have a
problem with fomo especially like i was
talking about earlier like just living
in l.a trying to do all the things i
remember it wasn't that long ago i'm
like mariah we don't do enough like
we're missing out on so much she's like
what are you talking she starts listing
things
i'm like oh yeah i guess we do we do do
a lot in los angeles but yeah there's
always like a concert i missed or a
comedy show i missed or a festival i
missed or an art you know art show i
missed
um
but i do i do
get more and more peace from it but
that's that is definitely something that
i struggle with and i do uh
i do start to
like when i get that feeling i do start
to kind of list out what
mariah and i have done and i do feel
more peaceful i'm like oh okay man like
you're you're out there experiencing it
you know you can't experience everything
it's okay
um yeah yeah i mean i'm lucky to
experience the things i experienced to
begin with let alone you know asking for
more
and why do we do any of these things
whether it's workaholism any kind of
addiction whether it's smoking
cigarettes drinking alcohol drinking
coffee that's my addiction right why do
we do these things well it's to chase
pleasure essentially right simulation
yeah
and why do we want pleasure it's really
running from pain and that's what fomo
is by the way when we're constantly
trying to go out and keep ourselves busy
keep our mind busy our hand busy our
time busy or our calendar busy
because of fomo
well what are we really afraid of it's
not missing out we're afraid of
being bored by ourselves yeah
we're afraid of spending time with
ourselves so we do whatever we can we
hop on youtube or twitter or instagram
or tick tock to spend time allowing
people to permeate our thoughts to maybe
manipulate our beliefs to make us want
to purchase things make us feel
inadequate right and
and when we do that
we are always going to feel like we're
missing out
and because we are missing out on a
meaningful relationship with ourselves
when we're outsourcing those thoughts to
uh we're outsourcing the control of our
thoughts to everyone else yeah
um let's move on to our callers you have
a question or a comment for our podcast
you can give us a call 406 219 7839 or
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
looks like we have a question here from
melanie in duluth minnesota
how
do you do time management i'm the sort
of person who needs a paper planner but
now it's at the point where i have a
paper planner with three inserts that i
keep swapping out and i don't find
planner piece
um so how do you function when you need
to write things down and you're not just
working from a screen
so melanie the
i hear the tension
in your voice
and you're looking for how to and yes
there are some cosmetic things you might
be able to do that will
improve your efficiency
but there's no how to here right this is
an understanding of what the real
problem is the problem isn't a lack of
franklin planners in your life right now
those tools can be helpful sure now some
tools might be helpful for you they
might get in the way for me i know
podcast shawn uses a uh like a a written
plan or a physical planner but for me
that would be an accoutrement that
simply got in the way however if i were
to hand him my system
he would be like oh this doesn't work
for me right i remember
when jessica
our social media manager she was having
a time of being disorganized in her life
and she finally found a
organizational tool that worked really
well for her it's something called asana
and i've tried to use that in the past
these different asana boards and
it added clutter to my life when she
explains it like it gets it got me
excited about it my god it's going to be
great but then like yeah i go to use it
and i'm like it just doesn't click for
me like it clicks for her
and that's okay
yeah and so what i'm going to ask
melanie is
it sounds like you want to escape the
excess here that's the title of this
episode but
really
you can escape the excess
only
by
not trying to escape here's what i mean
but because here's here's where you're
at right now oh it's so frantic it's so
frantic let me add more
more more more and more whatever it is
to the equation
as though more is going to get me out of
this right right
no your default state is peace you can't
plan peace she said planner peace
peace cannot be planned now we do get
confused and we think that we're
pursuing peace we're pursuing happiness
there are multiple kinds of happiness
there's the happiness
feeling that we get we have an
achievement or we buy something we get
that dopamine rush when we're on tick
tock and oh my gosh i watched that dance
video 13 times
that's a dopamine rush that's a feeling
of happiness
but it's not the human state of
happiness or peace or contentment which
is a default setting it cannot be
pursued it's not somewhere out there
you're not going to plan your way to
peace you're not going to plan your way
to happiness
you can the only path to peace is
realizing that it's already there you
the journey is that you're already there
you don't have to go anywhere to get
there
you are there already and so adding more
more and more more planning more
planners more commitments more
obligations more calendar clutter is
merely going to get in the way of your
piece
so what's on the other side of this if
peace is on the other side of the
clutter the calendar clutter
well how do you get there
by doing less by saying
no
so you can say yes to peace it doesn't
matter which calendar app you're using
to do that but having fewer things
planned out
will inherently bring you more peace
because you're not going from a to b to
c to d
that's the frenetic life i lived i
remember our meeting mondays back in the
corporate world
i had nine meetings in a row
nine one hour meetings back to back to
back to back to back in fact we would
even have a lunch meeting
and work through
lunch
to meet we had pre-meeting meetings we
had a one post meeting meeting we had a
pre-marketing meeting meeting
and so it was all really well planned
but there was very little peace there
you know that's saying uh every day we
stray further and further away from god
i think it should be uh every day we
stray further and further away from
peace yeah i mean that's
they say god is love god is peace
whatever you you know regardless what
your religious or spiritual beliefs are
all of the wisdom traditions recognize
an inner peace
and inner harmony
and we're trying to harmonize with the
world around us
but it's already going on inside you
right now um
melanie one other thing you can do is
you can set up some boundaries in your
life they help you say no to the things
that are less important i'd love for you
to download our free minimalist rule
book it's 16 rules for living with less
you can find it over the minimalists.com
rulebook
or podcast sean if you could reach out
to her send her the audiobook version
that's available now too and
uh secretly it's one of my favorite
things that we've ever done yeah ryan
and i got into the studio a couple years
ago
and we we just talked about all 16 rules
and invented some new rules on the fly
and so i would read out the rule and
then he and i would have this deep
conversation about it and it's uh two or
three hours long you can check that out
at the minimalists.com rulebook as well
but some of those rules in there they're
adjustable so allow you to set up some
boundaries anything outside of that
boundary you begin saying no to and it's
easier because anything within that
boundary you know i'm saying yes to this
and so when you're saying no to
something else you can tell people
actually i'm saying yes to the things
within bounds for me so i have to say no
to that
we got any questions from the live
stream alabama
we do we have a question here from kathy
what are some ways to keep my mind on
one priority when i have emotional
clutter that pulls my thoughts in all
directions worry fear failure not being
good enough ooh
man
and all about that those feelings in
that situation
uh for me
like meditation really helps
and it's so funny because it's such a
simple answer
and we hear that as an answer to a lot
of things but you know it's a it's a
cliche for a reason because it really
does help
help uh just help helps me stay focused
a little bit more
um the other thing too is maybe you know
kathy if there's like some things that
are constantly eating at you
um you might want to go you know get a
listening ear whether that's a friend or
whether it's a therapist like i've got
an awesome therapist and when
things eat at me i reach out to him and
i'm like hey man like i need i need to
talk to you for an hour like i need you
to help me like you know frame this in a
way that isn't gonna uh
that's gonna keep this thought from
basically ruining my days
um and and that to me that's when i
that's when i always need to go see a
therapist and talk to him is when like
i'm waking up and i have something on my
mind
and then you know make some coffee and
then it's on my mind and then i go to
eat lunch and then it's on my mind and
it's just doing that day after day after
day that's where i'm like oh wow like
this is actually preventing me from
having peace i need to go get some help
there let's do a little exercise here
because her name's kathy is that right
so
kathy
you mentioned four things i wrote down
worry fear
failure
not good enough
right you're afraid of not being good
enough and so here's one thing that we
almost never do we never stop and say
why um
okay why am i worried what's behind that
worry
and so
maybe
it is i'm worried that someone's going
to
reject me um well well why well because
i want to be accepted
why
oh because when i accept it i feel it
validates me
right i feel valid right
why is that important well because i
want to matter to other people why
and what you start to do is you ask
yourself why go 12 layers deep don't
stop
at the first or second answer keep doing
the why
why am i afraid
of failure
well because i want to project an image
onto the world that i am perfect
okay that's a one that i've certainly
struggled with in the past but as soon
as you
i you find the why behind that
it has to do with acceptance we talked
earlier about
the three ways to gain acceptance from
someone you can impress them you can be
with them where you can serve them
right
but as soon as you keep asking why you
realize that maybe you don't need their
acceptance
when you see people who really don't
give a damn right
if you
now most people affect that and they're
the people who care the most i don't
know why but hunter s thompson came to
mind right away he said people who don't
give it to him no he didn't right and he
didn't need anyone's acceptance
and the reason he didn't is he
understood
the why and the absurdity of needing
someone else's approval
because you can't control the way other
people feel about you yes you might have
a little bit of influence yeah
if you approach the world in a loving
caring way you may get many of
those same reactions back but it's
certainly not guaranteed and if you need
a particular outcome when interacting
with someone
then yes there's an expectation there
and that expectation
is going to lead to your discontent
because there's always going to be a
time where someone misses your
expectation
and now if you needed them to behave or
be a particular way and they haven't
well you're in for a world of
disappointment amen let's talk about
how we can't control the way other
people think about us okay because i
actually came across this uh yesterday
and
man how much detail do i want to give
let's just say
i'll just say that mariah and i are
having a conversation about someone who
is upset with me and this came up where
i was like oh we can't really i can't
control what people think of me
but then when i thought about how i
thought about this person i'm like
well their actions have actually
set up
my opinion of them
so in a way they did they can't control
the way i think of them does that make
sense so
is there a caveat there or am i like
help me clarify this yeah so let's say
let's say that you
were just constantly insulting me um you
know whatever ryan you're smelly hippy
and yeah you're you're too handsome i
don't like it
you know and other insults that i hear
all the time
but let's say that you were always
insulting me and then
you know not just through your words but
through your actions
you were constantly just showing me that
um i wasn't even on your radar you could
care less about me yada yada right so so
to that extent there is
some
control that you have over the way i
think of you does that make sense yes
you're absolutely right it's because
you're giving me that control though
if you didn't allow what i said to you
to do anything to you
you know if just like if i so if because
you have i've earned some a place in
your life
that you probably respect my feedback
more than the random person on the
street
and so
if i were to say something to you versus
a random person on the street said the
same exact thing
i'm probably gonna have more influence
over the way you react to it yeah
but when you recognize that
well i'm choosing to react that way and
i would choose to react differently i
would not take it as seriously when
someone else
is hurling insults at me i mean think
about if uh if a three-year-old started
insulting you like that'd be kind of
cute
right
yeah the cutest insults yeah right well
i mean all right so let's take you out
of the equation let's talk about the guy
in the corner yeah i mean there's not
literally a guy in the corner right now
but let's say there was and every time i
walked into the office he was just
treating me poorly
now i have an opinion of this man at
this point where he not like yeah i get
to choose how i react to him
but you know
um
the but what i think about him is is
based on his actions i guess let me let
me tell you where i got to and you tell
me if this is like the right viewpoint
or not so
it's
i the caveat of i can't control the way
people uh i can't control what people
think about me or the way that they see
me the caveat to that is
you know if i am
if i'm living like a genuine life
or if i am
uh
you know being
my true self however you want to look at
it
after that i can't control how people
think of me
is that is that not i don't know man
help me help help me with that
you're you're right i mean
what people think about you might
change the way that you behave
and
and so it depends on what you mean by
your true self right because we all have
personalities your personality is merely
your mask that you i'm going to show
myself to the world this way
and maybe it's relatively congruent to
your internal self
but there's always a filter through
which people see you
your identity that you've created for
yourself right
and so yes there are people in your life
who they will affect the way you behave
but they don't have to
affect you you're essentially
outsourcing
that
power to them
and i get it like i want to be around
people who treat me kindly as well but
when that becomes my need
hmm
i'm imprisoning myself with their with
their outcomes
yeah maybe it's more of the lines of
like i can't
control how
people perceive me
because the perception is
very
um individual
and
one person might look at ryan nicodemus
and say oh he's a really swell guy and
someone else might look at him and be
like oh he's he's so out of touch with
reality whatever it is
um
and at that point i have no i have no
control over how someone perceives me
but if i am
you know if i'm going around like
causing harm to people
then there is i mean that that that's
going to create you know this this
thought of hey ryan nicodemus is a jerk
you know yeah yeah and so what are your
intentions behind that and and so of
course we're not talking about violence
here
right that's a separate thing
we can set that aside but think about
someone like garyvee for example
who was supposed to be on on the show
and then we had a thing it didn't work
out
but
when i think about someone like gary vee
people are very polarized about some
people think oh my gosh look at this guy
he's like
the messiah of hustle right right the
patron saint of hustle yeah and other
people are like oh my god i can't stand
that guy right right
and if he was constantly trying to get
validation from the people who were like
i can't stand that guy
then he'd have to change his behavior in
a way that actually harmed the people
who
did
appreciate what he does
and so
we get caught up because what we try to
do and then we try to be a chameleon i'm
going to be a particular way for ryan
i'm going to be a different way for this
person and for mallory and for podcast
shawn and for jordan we get exhausted
trying to wear a bunch of different
masks and someone like me who's a three
on the enneagram
it's easy for me to be like okay how
would what's the best way to identify
with podcast sean or with danny unknown
right how do i identify with well i put
on a slightly different mask
and that's what my former self would
have done with regularity right yeah as
opposed to simply showing up and being
me right because it's much less about
how
people don't remember your words they
remember how you approach the world
and so
how you walk into a room how you hug
people or or your demeanor around other
people
you encounter a negative person and you
give them good news they'll find a way
to spin it negatively right if you give
negative news to an extremely optimistic
person not because they ask that
optimism because they are truly
optimistic you can give them bad news
and they'll find the
the their own individual
authentic spin
as to how you can learn from this for me
suffering is one of those things but
suffering is one of the worst thing
that's worst best things that's ever
happened to me
because it rearranges all of your
perspective
right yeah and so
yes
how you approach the world
people will see that and via their own
lens because they have their own baggage
they're carrying into that situation
i can't believe ryan is so gregarious it
really turns me off so what are you
going to do you're going to turn that
down are you going to stop showing up
right because you stop showing up then
the people you're loving
also lose out on the best version of you
yeah so that's what it is it's like if
you're trying to put on a mask like
that's it's going to make you miserable
because like there's not enough masks
for you to wear
and by the way one mask is gonna please
someone and it's gonna displease another
without a doubt right so all you can do
is show up and be you
and that's all you can do yes and and
there are versions of you as well and
understanding that because
if i i'm an extreme introvert so i spent
all my time around a bunch of other
people i would become drained and i
would be a lesser version of my peak
self or ideal self right and so by being
able to retreat and be alone more
frequently i'm able to show up when i am
around people and be
a more ideal version of me now it
doesn't mean that the drained version of
me is not actually me it is me when i'm
drained and and so understanding
that part of me if i've run out of
energy run out of gas
then to step back and and to recharge in
those situations now for someone like
you
it might mean you have a much
fuller tank than me
and you're able to show up but also
recognizing that some people aren't
going to have a a positive reaction to
someone who's outgoing and charismatic
yeah but that's not up to you to
determine their reaction right they're
going to have their reaction regardless
and the more i need them to have a
particular reaction the more i'm
imprisoned by my own desires yeah ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions your comments to
area code 937-202-4654
yes indeed now during the lightning
round that's where ryan and i do our
best to answer questions of the short
shareable less than 140 character
response who put the text to these
minimal maximums in the show notes so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like you can
also find all of our minimal maxims in
one place minimal
maxims.com ryan i wrote down a few
minimal maxims i wanted to share with
respect to excess before we get to
kristen's question here cool let's do it
these aren't from me necessarily well
one of them is but uh one's from henry
david thoreau
a man is rich in proportion to the
number of things which he can afford to
let alone hmm
a man is rich in proportion to the
number of things
which he can afford to let alone
interesting i thought that comment was
going in a completely different
direction but yeah that's yeah that's
great so the more that we
need the more that we can't let alone
oh i really need the bigger house i need
the salary i need the job title i need
the studio i need whatever it is
the more that i need the less rich i
become right when i need next to nothing
then everything that i get becomes a
gift
that i can experience when i don't need
it
when i recognize i already have enough
enough isn't on the other side of the
mountain
just like happiness isn't on the other
side of the mountain or contentment or
joy it's all
here
right now regardless of what your
religious or spiritual beliefs are
you have
enough
and the things that we put around us
if we're not careful they become excess
really quickly and that excess
makes us less rich
so you can have a rich man
a truly wealthy
individual
with
multi-million dollar bank account
who's
impoverished by desire impoverished by
their need to acquire more impoverished
by their need to impress other people
impoverished by their desire for
acceptance among peers and followers
makes me think of emcee hammer
[Music]
i mean how much did he get 50 million 60
million something yeah and he was
bankrupt with within 10 years and why
was that because he because of his
desires now
he was a very giving man
so you know he basically
made an announcement in like the
neighborhood he grew up in hey if you
need a job come and ask me i won't turn
you down yeah so he you know he employed
a lot of people he had a big heart yes
but he also had a really big house
[Laughter]
takes a big house to hold that big heart
of his um
but yeah i mean it's yeah it's just it's
exactly what you're talking about like
because of his need
uh because of his needs uh yeah he ended
up going broke when he he was richer
than you and i will ever be he had a
well-decorated prison cell so to speak
here's another one that we all know
about the things you own end up owning
you
it's from chuck palahniuk yeah in uh his
book fight club
and
well what does that say about excess it
means the things that we own
they amplify us but they own us
when we cling to them
when we must have them
when we can't live without them
now
they own us
and then here's a short one for you this
is from theminimalists.com
our possessions dispossess
and so
to dispossess means to remove property
remove land or remove something from
someone right
but as we get more things those things
remove something from our lives a
purpose or meaning
that we
experience without those things and so
as we accumulate more and more our
possessions dispossess yeah
it is great like the more you get the
more you realize like
it's
the possessions are never enough
like it is uh
like i feel like i have enough right now
i mean i i am fortunate enough to like
be able to live in la and you know food
on the table pay my utilities yadda
yadda yadda yadda
but you know i feel like i have enough
because you know those basic needs are
met and my desires are very low for for
more and i've you know we've been
practicing over the last 11 years to get
to that point right but um
you know even me
like moving to la i i started to get
this twinge of like
oh man it'd be really nice to have a
tesla it'd be really nice to own a house
here in l.a it'd be really like all
these things that never in my life did i
think i would
you know
really well i shouldn't say never in my
life but over the last 10 years like i
wouldn't think that i'd come to l.a and
have those feelings but
i was i'm able to kind of see the the
truth behind those desires
and kind of hit them head on so not to
say that i don't have those desires but
i can process them a little bit
differently where
um
a lot of people don't know how to
process those desires they just think
well the way to process it is to get it
and then i'll then i'll be complete yes
but it's but like i just remember the
the tran the
transgression from living in dayton ohio
we became the minimalists
we wrote a book and then we started
going on tour
and every city we went to was like this
new awesome experience and i'll never
forget like you know the first time
going to portland the first first time
coming to la the first time going to san
francisco
but specifically saskatoon yes saskatoon
i'll never forget that red lobster
but you know it's uh it's it's
interesting though because
we were living in dayton my rent was
450 bucks i mean it was like it was
super cheap in pickup ohio
and
uh we come out to la we go to san
francisco new york city you know you
start to ask how much does it cost to
live in this city yeah
and then you start to find out rent
prices and you're like oh my god right i
could never afford to live in x city
yeah and then here i am living in x city
and now i'm like i'll never be able to
afford a tesla i'll never be able to
afford m.c hammer's home
[Laughter]
and and some of these things might be
true
mm-hmm
i'll never be able to afford m.c hammers
home and if i am i would never buy it
anyway right right right and so
the tesla thing is interesting because
nothing wrong with owning a tesla right
i like coal powered cars yes exactly
no yeah and my point is that by own
electric vehicle
you might actually be doing something
that is really helpful for the
environment the question is can i afford
all of the other costs involved because
when we're talking about excess we're
not just talking about the excess cost
of a thing and excess debt that's a big
part of it for sure because you want
excess stress
excess discontent go into debt
and that's an easy shortcut it's the
worst to anxiety that is the worst kind
of stress right and so
what you're what you've identified is i
already have enough and if at some point
a tesla makes sense i don't have to have
it
but it'd be okay if i did too yeah but
as soon as i need it for happiness
contentment
love whatever it is we start to need all
of these things that are external to us
i need a relationship in order to love
well no you can be loving without a
relationship without being married you
can still be
loving yeah oh i need this house
in order to live well no you don't need
to own a house to live well
you can live well without a house you
can live well in a house as well i need
the right job in order to be accepted by
people in my circle
nope you don't need a job to be accepted
all you need to do is serve other people
or if you could take it farther you can
just stop needing to be accepted right
but there are easier ways even if you
want to get acceptance
to become accepted by other people and
so
we have all of this excess we have
relationship access we have calendar
access and we certainly have material
possession
excess
and we have that because
we think
happiness is right around the corner
and it is but it's here as well
so you can travel around the corner and
you'll be bringing happiness with you we
just got to stop covering up with the
things that are making us so unhappy
because happiness is a default state and
if you want to learn how to let go
here's how you do it you realize that
your default setting
is not discontentment
you've been taught by advertisers and by
corporations and by marketers that your
default state is to be discontent
no your default state is contentment
it's peace it's joy it's love
and it can only be covered up
by excess
we have a question here from kristin
i've tried so many apps to help me stay
organized but have made little progress
do you have any tips on how to cut down
on excessive screen time here's my pithy
answer for you you need to buy more apps
great answer milburn have you checked
out the minimalist's new app
just kidding we don't have an app uh
although if we did it'd be fine no we do
have an app the nothing app oh we did so
this is a you can go to youtube type in
the minimalists the nothing app we'll
put a link to it in the show notes
that's even better uh we did an april
fools joke the nothing app it's
wonderful here's my pithy answer for you
since we're running out of time kristen
if poisoned by excess more poison will
not save you it reminded me when we were
at a live event someone came up to the
mic and they're like you know i've
bought all the financial books i've
bought the financial courses and i just
can't seem to get my money problems
under control
and my pithy answer was like you can't
spend your way out of debt and this is
very similar you can't you cannot app
your way out of disorganization
kristin for the sake of time i'm gonna i
was gonna go dive deep into
six best practices
to reduce the digital clutter in your
life i'm going to save that for the
maximal episode this week because ryan
has something pithy for you yes my pith
answer is this an app
can't take action only you can and that
is where i think you might be
getting tripped up here there's not an
app that is going to take the action for
you it's it's you taking the action
yourself quite often the app apes the
form of action i downloaded the app why
isn't my life better right and apps can
help organize and like i'm not saying
that apps aren't useful
but they are a tool it's not the it's
not you're not you cannot uh sublease or
sublet your
uh your your action to an app that's
right yeah it might help you just like a
hammer can help a carpenter but the
carpenter buys a hammer and it doesn't
do the work yeah i bought the hammer and
the nails i don't know what's going on
why isn't this house built now
and so buying the thing apes the form of
taking some sort of action but that's
not real
action yeah
and it's certainly not understanding and
kristen what i want to help you with is
the understanding so on the maximum of
this episode this week i'll do six best
practices
to help with digital clutter and to
reduce your excessive screen time we got
a bunch more to talk about but real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists
i usually teach a four-week writing
class it's called how to write better
you can find it over at
howtorightbetter.org
you can download my free ebook over
there it's called 15 ways to write
better but we don't have a open class
right now but we're getting ready to do
a two-hour workshop sean mahalik my
adjunct professor and i he's going to do
this workshop with me on may 29th it's a
two-hour workshop if you can attend live
you'll be able to ask questions i'm also
going to go over
these different rules to improve your
writing i want to help you learn how to
write better in just two hours it's for
folks who can't necessarily afford the
the time or the money for the larger
four-week class well now there's a
one-day two-hour workshop that will be
able to spend some time together on may
29th it'll also be available thereafter
if you buy a ticket beforehand
howardwrightbetter.org for all the
details alabama here are some uh
voicemail comments what do you got for
us here's some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
philly from the uk here
i've been catching up on your podcast
and occasionally hear people who want to
give up convenience shopping such as
amazon to help them avoid mindless
consumption
this won't work for everyone but i have
found that i can often completely switch
off the desire for a brand if i look
into their production in more detail
this could be the way they treat people
the planet animals how they deal with
toxic waste what they invest in and so
on
in the uk this information is easily
found with the magazine ethical consumer
but i do pay to subscribe to them some
of their research is free i don't know
if there is a us equivalent but they do
cover many global brands
i find this helps me create a barrier to
easy consumption and it has helped me
avoid acquiring countless items over the
past few years and also ensures i'm very
intentional about what i do by hopefully
this could help others too
my name is betsy i'm from upstate new
york i have a message for jean the woman
on your podcast about building a tiny
house
and she was looking for ways to minimize
her kitchen
i
recommend
looking into an instant pot
it's a all-in-one pressure cooker slow
cooker rice cooker yogurt maker i
it's best if you uh youtube or google it
rather than listen to me rave about it
but it sure saves a lot of space and
it saves on extra appliances
all right joe before we get to our added
value segment this week here's a lovely
comment from one of our thoughtful
private podcast supporters over on
patreon jordan brooks says hello joshua
and ryan i just have to say that i love
you guys oh we love you too jordan i
just finished listening to all of the
free minimalist episodes then i tried to
listen to a different podcast but as
soon as i started it i was forced to
listen to the same mcdonald's
advertisement twice
and it made me realize how much i value
the minimalists and all the patrons who
make this podcast advertisement free so
i stopped the other podcast and joined
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon i'm super happy to be here that
is that's awesome that's
you know what man i'm
what we're doing is uh adding value to
people's lives by removing the
advertisements man i love that cause
like i'll listen to whatever
and
yeah as soon as an ad pops up i'm like
why why right in the middle of this
thing like at least when a tv show does
it it's like a nice clean break
it's like yeah we'll be back
anyway yeah even then it's so like oh it
is and so jordan thank you and by the
way for those of you who aren't
supporting the private podcast it's a
completely separate show every week
every thursday we do an hour or two
hours sometimes three hours occasionally
and we dive deep into some things we
don't typically talk about in public so
this isn't like a bonus content club
where you get table scraps no most of
what we create is actually over on the
private podcast every thursday and also
all of our archives are over there
hundreds of hours of minimalism you
don't want to listen to it all
necessarily but start with the most
recent ones and find the ones that are
going to add the most value to your life
there's so much gold over there on the
private podcast things that we don't
bring on to the public podcast every
thursday you can check out the maxwell
episode it's completely separate episode
patreon.com the minimalist for our added
value this week ryan
i think i might call an audible on this
one yeah i'm going to call an audible
since we're talking about stuff
i don't want to be an ascetic although
we're going to talk about asceticism on
the
maximal episode this week i'm actually
going to recommend a few things that
have been useful for me i'm not going to
prescriptionize it though but i'm going
to call an audible here so uh sean start
playing a song for me right now it's
called new shoes by paulo nutini it came
out in uh 2006. remember that song right
this is
[Music]
anyway i got these new pair of shoes
here oh nice and i used to wear toms all
the time if you're watching the video
version you can see my shoe here this is
not a sponsored ad it's certainly not an
advertisement they don't send me shoes
if they're comfy if they tried to send
me shoes i'd say no thank you
are those rubber is that rubber or is it
cloth
it is uh top secret material space
it's very aerodynamic the what's the bra
i don't even know the brand suaves
s-u-a-v-s
oh well from back here it looks like
vans that's i was like these look
similar to vans yeah but they're i used
to wear toms but the quality of them i
used to always remove the logos because
i hate logos of my things this one has
you can barely see it here
but uh they're super comfortable and i
have wide feet so that my feet fit in
these really well
and they're they're very comfortable and
i walk a lot so i walk maybe eight miles
a day on average they got these insoles
here i dig them in and uh it just and
you can replace wash the insoles you can
replace them they're breathable they're
super breathable you can see actually
like how breathable they are i didn't
wear toms for two reasons one my feet
sweat so much yes that like i would blow
them out like they would just they
started smelling really funky but then
also like
let's say you get past the smell and i
would wear them like yeah like i needed
to replace them like every six months or
so like the quality wasn't that good and
so i went and bought a couple pairs of
these because i wear them pretty much
every day now dude and i'm not
recommending them to you here because
here's the truth
you probably don't need some new shoes
right now so please don't go out and buy
some new shoes and also these shoes they
work really well for me they might not
work for you
just like the shoes that ryan wears he
wears those zero shoes and those didn't
really work well for me for whatever
reason and it doesn't mean they were
awesome for him and so i'm not saying go
out and buy some new shoes but if you
are looking for some new shoes
eventually these have worked really well
for me and plus i really enjoy paulo
nutini's new shoes song
which is playing in the background still
right now
by the way ryan we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are 21 principles for radically
simplifying your life
how do we manage
expectations from others that exceed our
own is it possible to quit social media
without cutting off my social
connections plus a million more
questions for the minimalist and if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week i
already gave you all the details but you
also get access to all the archives live
events ask the minimalist anything
sessions a whole bunch of stuff we've
created over there for you at
patreon.com
the minimalist also an open-minded
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tiktok instagram facebook
and twitter
at the minimalist if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown triple p
that's a pot post-production peter
was that the winner yeah i think so nice
peter duff mixing by the way he uh he
mixes the episodes for us we're calling
him triple p now triple p all right all
right emma the immigrant and the rest of
our team i'm joshua fields milburn if
you leave here today with
just one message let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see ya
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it